sean el eje funciones definidas por fx
igual a 1 x más elevado a la x al
cuadrado menos 2x gx igual a x a la
cuarta menos 6.5 x al cuadrado más 6 x
más 2 sean r&s las dos regiones entre
las gráficas de fg mostradas en la
figura de arriba aquí tenemos a las
funciones f y g que encierran a las
regiones rs veamos qué dice el inciso a
dice encuentra la suma de las áreas de
las regiones r y s
entonces la suma de las áreas de las
regiones e&r s es lo que queremos
encontrar así que piensa lo diremos de
x0 a x2
entonces el área de r s es igual a la
integral desde x0 a x2 y que vamos a
integrar vamos a integrar el valor
absoluto de la diferencia entre las dos
funciones y tomamos el valor absoluto
porque no queremos sumar áreas negativas
queremos la suma de las áreas de las
regiones r&s ahora observa aquí ves que
x está arriba de fx pero luego fx está
arriba deje de x al tomar el valor
absoluto no va a importar el orden de la
resta de las funciones porque estarás
sacando el valor absoluto de la
diferencia de las funciones por lo tanto
tenemos la integral de 0 a 2 del valor
absoluto de fp x - g de x
x
esto será la suma de las áreas de las
regiones e&r y s
que es igual a la integral de 0 a 2 del
valor absoluto de fx es uno más x más
elevado a x al cuadrado menos 2x y le
restamos gx entonces menos gtx que es
igual menos x a la cuarta más 6.5 x al
cuadrado menos 6x menos 2 y aquí cambie
el signo porque estamos restando ag x
entonces el signo cambia
tomo el valor absoluto de eso de x
entonces vamos a resolver esta integral
en la calculadora así que
enciendo la calculadora y vamos a
definir la expresión de la integral como
1 entonces tomó el valor absoluto o
primo matemática después número y ahí
está valor absoluto así que tenemos el
valor absoluto de uno más
x
más
elevado a la x al cuadrado menos 2x
ahora cierra ese paréntesis menos x a la
cuarta
más
6.5 x al cuadrado menos
6 x
- 2 cierro paréntesis del valor absoluto
entonces eso es eso 1 y ahora vamos a
evaluar la integral definida oprimimos
el botón de matemática y bajamos a la
función integral ahí está vamos a usar
que es uno entonces vamos a variables
variable que entonces en la primera
opción donde dice función seleccionamos
y es 1 nuestra variable de integración
es x
y las cotas de la integral son desde x0
a x2 entonces de 0 a 2
y obtenemos
una aproximación de 2.004 así que esto
es aproximadamente 2.000 4